alors qu'eric et vous êtes devenu un
good guys un bon garçon et on va faire
une interview good guys
est ce que est ce que vous buvez encore
un peu quand même
oui mais juste un problème
ouais votre chronique pas de problème
est-ce que vous fumez des pétards de
temps en temps pas autant qu'avant mais
ça m'arrive
serait ce sont les banel récupérer j'en
ai besoin après cette émission est ce
que vous êtes passés devant un juge
depuis moins d'un an
oui je suis passé devant un juge
j'ai perdu mon permis de conduire dont
je les récupère entre temps mais enfin
j'ai permis accueil permis permis
conduite parce que je faisais trop vite
bien et beaucoup trop vite vous mettez
des pots catalytiques à vos ferrari en
fait toutes les feuilles sont équipées
de pots catalytiques
absolument et si vous partiez des
chapeaux il sera en fourrure synthétique
oui complètement non en fourrure
naturelle jamais jamais est ce que
maintenant vous êtes un goût de gaye est
ce que vous pensez que rien n'est plus
beau que le sourire d'un enfant 'j'ai
raconte quelque chose si bien que good
game il faut pas exagérer nous
j'ai toujours bien les minettes qui
portent des mini jupes et des jeux et
des bottes ajustements ben justement est
ce que vous demandez toujours la carte
d'identité d'une fan avant de coucher
avec elle pour être sûr fallait pas
mineur mon dieu non non non est ce que
maintenant vous êtes un goût de galles
vous rêvez d'un duo avec mariah carey
dont la dernière fois que je les ai vus
d'ailleurs elle s'est pointée comme ça
avec les gens qui l'entourent et j'étais
là dans le couloir et les venues elle
est passée comme ça que je te fasse du
buzz nomades est-ce que vous pensez que
l'amour pourrait sauver le monde
si vous débarrasser de georges bush dick
cheney donald rumsfeld
peut-être que l'on pourrait sauver le
monde
jaguar
jean lebas joie
pioneer au point en tournée
dejean le lot 2
bonheur
5 je vends comme i thank you
m